[Musica]
ce la puoi fare
ce la puoi fare ce la può non ce la
posso fare
ultimamente ho notato non senza una
buona dose di pregiudizio che i film ei
telefilm pseudo seri italiani sono molto
più divertenti di quelli comici è vero è
una frase un po qualunquista però è
anche un po vera e la web series the
lady nell esempio lampante serie di
dieci puntate su youtube scritta e
diretta da lory del santo e questa web
siria si è diventata un fenomeno
mediatico del web perché fa cagare e che
quando mai riescono ad acchiappare
qualcosa di bello dal web e per
settimane la gente non faceva altro che
parlare di questo fare parodie a fare
recensioni eccetera eccetera mi sono
visto questi video rivisto le puntate
più volte e solo adesso deciso di
parlarne ma come avrei mai potuto
recensire un intera stagione un'intera
serie di dieci puntate e togliervi dalla
bocca quel gusto di potervela vedere da
voi quindi ho deciso che insieme vedremo
soltanto il primo episodio perché state
tranquilli che basta e avanza
e potrebbe anche diventare una piccola
serie di video questa tipo parlare di
del primo episodio di qualcosa come fa
già qualcuno per esempio il dottor
manhattan
questo è il primo episodio di the lady
la prima puntata inizia con dei suoni
che sono sicuro siano quelli che senti
durante un trip di lsd
[Musica]
siccome di lady è una serie che vuole
rappresentare le donne nel modo più
realistico possibile e non come mero
oggetto sessuale
la nostra protagonista si spara un
monologo interiore in sexy lingerie ho
toccato il confine del dolore ma ho
anche avuto il coraggio di combattere
obiettivo raggiunto io credevo che
windows movie maker fosse andato fuori
commercio invece guarda che titoli di
testa accattivanti che riesce a creare
[Musica]
oddio che spavento fammi mettere a posto
lo speck
no no frega nulla non lascio lì dopo
essersi vestita a metà cambiato stanza e
solo adesso essersi messa la giacca
perché la camera da letto non è
abbastanza intima per indossare una
giacca raggiunge la sua guardia del
corpo antonio mentre uno con una
cicatrice in faccia la osserva da
lontano perché beh perché lei e veneti
lei la donna che tutti vorrebbero avere
e che vorrebbero essere potere controllo
bellezza due stanze diverse per vestirsi
e un sogno salita in auto conosciamo
anche il suo autista a salvatore devo
incontrare un amico al palazzo dei
congressi le parti link grazie signora
per lei fare qualsiasi cosa
i suoi english berna la lascia mai
[Musica]
non ho capito ho pensato a questo
dialogo per settimane senza mai capire
il senso ragazzo e questo invece humor
nella frase signora lei fare qualsiasi
cosa
ricky gervais fatti da parte salvatore
l'autista e la nuova rivelazione
britannica è scesa dall'auto incontrano
un suo collega leggermente espansivo ma
vengono visti da costantino vitagliano
che dovrebbe essere il suo ragazzo tra
l'altro un salutone a costantino
vitaliano che ci segue sempre che era da
anni che non vedevo vedo che hai fatto
carriera solo tempo io ti amo dovresti
rispettare il mio sentimento simt sexy
meglio tenersi nella mia vita
wow wow non solo i dialoghi sono
recitati dalla rappresentazione umana di
c3po ma probabilmente sono anche stati
scritti da lui cioè sono riusciti a far
fare facepalm allo stesso costantino ai
tra l'altro tenete a mente questo
dialogo klimt sexy non voglio tenerti
nella mia vita ci serviamo devo andare
per seguire un servizio fotografico una
campagna pubblicitaria di costume da
bagno
così va e quella frazione di secondo di
scavalcamento di campo l'hanno inserito
tipo i frame porno in fight club mi
fermo a napoli per incontrare un nuovo
cliente e poi parigi non ha ma cos'è
l'amore per te beh beh meno male che
quella domanda non era assolutamente
fuori contesto e buttata a caso
altrimenti si sarebbe creato imbarazzo
non ha ma cos'è l'amore per te ne frega
la confonde col del ieri
il mio lato è un uomo per lei che uomo
sei stato chiarissimo fanno passare e
ciao mamma sono io
no non ho niente che volevo solo dirti
che ti voglio bene perché sai non sai
mai quello che potrebbe accadere il
giorno prima stai benissimo il giorno
dopo si trasformano in uno stereotipo
caricaturale su gambe sì se non mollo
tengo duro
ciao vi presento chang e ancora adesso
non capisco perché non sia lui il
protagonista lo voglio su tutte le
copertine delle riviste lo voglio ospite
dalla d'urso a fare spottoni della sua
carriera d'attore e lo voglio al cinema
con il suo primo lungometraggio all'urlo
di chang e terrorizza anche l'occidente
voglio un chang nella mia vita mentre
lei e doris la segretaria della levi e
l'uomo un uomo che è arrivato e il suo
ragazzo
non voglio fare certo battute sul fatto
che i suoi capelli suoi vestiti e i suoi
baffi e di coordino molto i protagonisti
delle videocassette che si trovavano in
edicola negli anni 90 ma qualche dubbio
mi è venuto per me con tessuto sciotta
mia come ti desidero conosciuto mia come
ti desidero una frase che farebbe stragi
di cuori nelle cartoline di san
valentino subito dopo incontro un suo
amico per strada rivelandogli la verità
a sé doris ti sei fatta una bonazza si
compiace in istinti animaleschi ai tuoi
cosa scusa compiace in istinti
animaleschi perfetto abbiamo anche
trovato un titolo del film ma ti faccio
una confidenza lei permesso un gioco io
voglio la sua boss da levin mi capisci o
no che piano diabolico che a questo
personaggio che apparirà solo un paio di
volte per tutta la serie the lady torna
a casa
bentornato a signora a samir portato
bene
ma sorpresa c'è costantino ad aspettarla
incazzato nero di te non ci si può
fidare ma cosa credi di prendermi in
giro ti ho vista larsen mi tradisce
l'origine tutte palle laura
non ti basto io mi manca qualcosa il
talento bello continua ora che non ti fa
rivedere mai più
devo metterti in riga esci dalla mia
casa chiama la sicurezza va bene me ne
va si battere beh tu si che sei un vero
uomo
devo metterti riga maria ok talvolta
nella vita si paga di più per quello che
non si è commesso
sì se non l'hai commesso ma ti rinfresco
la memoria tim flex mai a tenerti nella
mia vita quindi non posso far altro che
risponde piccolo un banale ma sempre
verde [ __ ] [ __ ] di s per far
capire che lei è forte fuori ma fragile
dentro va in palestra con una maglia con
su scritto lussuria epirb antella dopo
aver finito il suo allenatore che è
praticamente la forma umana di una
nuvola speedy si lascia andare a
raffinati sillogismi aristotelici simone
certo che loro è una gran bella gnocca
elevata vuole affrontarlo elevata
vorrei affrontarla elevata vuole
agguantarla
ma parla come mangi cretino ma
costantino non si dà per vinto e non
toccherò mai più con un dito look non mi
ami abbastanza bene così non riesce ad
accettarmi per come sono mi piace
flirtare con gli uomini giocare ma lo
sai che non ti tradirà mai
ah sì solo queste le parole che un uomo
vuol sentirsi dire stiamo insieme per
sempre
sì ma solo se ci sono altri beni o no
more io voglio stare con te ma ci devono
essere altri beni nella mia vita io sono
una donna che sa quel che vuole
chiaro ma tu mi stravolge tiri fuori la
bestia che ci è arrivato l'animale
prossima stagione ti facciamo lottare
per il titolo di presi più ma zhang e ho
l'impressione che qualcuno mi segue e mi
controlli se vedi qualcosa di strano
dimmelo subito ok grandissimo c'hanno
oscar alla carriera
la lady per farsi consolare chiama
gisele una coppia di attrici gemelle mi
innamoro sempre degli uomini sbagliati
allora deduco che per innamorarsi gli
uomini devono essere sbagliati hai un
grande senza della juve ma basta trovare
humour dove non c'è scusa non è che per
caso lavori come il talent scout per
colorado megli il sud
no perché si capirebbero molte cose alla
fine della puntata la signora parte per
capri facendosi portare 837 valigie da
chang e samir questo era il primo
episodio di the lady non ce la posso
fare
non capisco se vada preso sul serio o no
sembra che voglio farti arrivare un
messaggio
ma si perde in dialoghi usciti da una
realtà parallela e personaggi con mille
sfaccettature ma neanche una fatta come
si deve
consiglio vivamente a tutti di vedervi
tutte e dieci le puntate che trovate su
youtube perché abbiamo solo scrostato la
punta dell'iceberg
non vorrei spammare troppo però un giro
sulla pagina facebook vi consiglierei di
farla perché li spostano i messaggi di
complimenti dei fan tipo calori siamo
due giovani design
tranesi anche per noi del e vi è stata
una grande scoperta
riteniamo sia un prodotto che rispecchia
fedelmente una certa realtà esistente
oggi e abbiamo apprezzato l'ironia
graffiante che smaschera le
contraddizioni di loan a e dei
personaggi che la circondano
internet è un posto magico
[Musica]
signora che è un uomo per lei